let's go next to our caller from the
4:08 area code
who's there from photo 8 Hey hello all
right I want to ask a question how come
we don't have any more people in
politics today sorry how come we don't
have what people Center people people
that can go on both sides of the party
yeah I mean mostly I would argue it's
because of how politics are financed
right so increasingly as the general
population moderates and really moves to
the left on a lot of issues you still
have a lot of the money being raised
from number one interest groups that
tend to not have the most moderate
positions and you have money raised from
people with more extreme positions so
like even though for example gay
marriage is a settled issue legally
where you can't have bans on gay
marriage at the state level anymore you
still have a lot of money raised by sort
of placating the extreme religious right
groups for whom it still is an issue
even though legally it's resolved so
that's a big reason why moderates have a
tougher time winning yeah but for other
issues like the Iran nuclear deal it's
saying I think it's good to have people
on both sides explain the situation and
come to somewhere where you know we'll
take a little bit for what you said and
we'll take a little bit from what the
other guy said and let's come to a
compromise here yeah that's interesting
but I do want to just mention that
there's this idea that if you just kind
of average the position of the left and
the position of the right on any issue
that what you get in the middle is sort
of acceptable and reasonable oftentimes
the facts are not just in the middle of
the left and right wing position right
so at its core I think it's important
not to fall into that logical fallacy
that if you just take listen take an
extreme view on a homophobic view from
the right and a pro-gay view from the
left and average it and you'll come out
with something that's like slightly
homophobic so then everybody's happy you
got to be careful with that you got to
be careful that I don't think that
that's that's the right way to go
it's true but I'm also talking about
sort of like military strategy spending
you know something that's not to do with
civil liberties and civil right it's
more of just didn't they're expanding
government options in general yeah I
mean the thing is I kind of mostly do
have consensus on that from our elected
officials because those are the systems
that got them into power in the first
place
which is why we're not seeing any
progress on fixing the campaign
financing issues so I think it's a good
point and a well-made one I appreciate
it